good health arturo mejía with his
informative watch for today, thursday
first of july, the
law school and high school are in mourning today
after the death of one of their students,
according to the forensic doctor, the 13-
year-old suffered a medical episode
during training  athletic on Monday afternoon
the prosecution will not seek the death penalty
for 'the road' is the man accused of
killing the two-year-old child they are sailors
in brothers confessed to killing the
child while the child's mother
was away she was arrested  yesterday
on charges of prostitution
and people earning the minimum wage
are about to receive a raise the
state law was passed in 2019 and requires
the increase of 75 cents each year
until 2024 the minimum hourly wage for
employees with medical benefits
will now be 8  dollars and 75 cents for
those without medical benefits
will receive a minimum hourly wage of
9 dollars and 75 cents by the year 2024
this will rise to 12 dollars  es
and the las vegas' light soccer
team has expanded their family this coming
saturday they will reveal their new mascot and
although its name will be a surprise it is
known that the new member will be a
mother who will serve as a companion for the
current team mascot tali clama  the
team is excited the reveal
will be the end of the game against tacoma on
saturday there will also be a
fireworks show tickets are 10
dollars for adults and 5 for children
now we go to the weather conditions
with mostly clear skies and
low humidity today thursday  the sun will be
hotter than yesterday temperatures are expected
to reach 100 degrees
electrical storms could be seen in the mountains
and for the rest of the holiday weekend it
returns to triple digits to the
valley with highs of 105 degrees keep
a nice diary i am hector mejía and  this
was their brief information about them in
Spanish
[Music]